we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is a caller asking
about how can it be good to eat
vegetables if babies don't like them
it's weird take a listen to this
hi David in the context of evolution
yeah how is it possible that we eat
vegetables and fruits given
children's reactions to them you know
it's like pulling teeth to get a child
to try
a piece of what they used to like
throughout history
why did we eat
oh I think I think I know it's because
we have no other options available and
um
compared to anything else
you know if you're starving it's like
hunger is the best place okay I answer
my own question thanks a lot David for
for not doing anything useful to help
and leading me to my oh boy so anyway
how do vegetables make sense in terms of
human evolution and babies don't like
them listen my daughter likes every
vegetable and every fruit I mean sure
mango how can anybody not like a mango
but raspberry blackberry pear you know
everything
um I don't really know what the caller's
talking about how could it be I guess
the idea would be if if babies and
little kids instinctively reject fruits
and vegetables it would suggest that
evolutionarily blah blah blah well but
babies also don't forage for food on
their own so it doesn't really matter
it's a matter of whether the parents are
giving the babies fruits and vegetables
and it makes a lot of evolutionary sense
because they provide essential nutrients
and vitamins and minerals and
antioxidants so you know sugar that
gives us energy satisfies sweet cravings
and fruit and it seems to me that eating
fruits and vegetables is perfectly in
line with Evolution although it sounds
like the collar doesn't actually need my
help figuring it out I don't know uh if
you have anything you want to ask or say
you can call 219 to David P on the bonus
show today oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad we
will talk about a U.S fighter jet
response to an unresponsive aircraft
near Washington DC the aircraft
ultimately crashed near in Virginia what
happened there we will discuss Saudi
Arabia cutting oil production
specifically to increase prices this
time acting unilaterally some in the U.S
aren't happy what does it all mean we
will discuss it and lastly what's
happening with Disney is just so so
funny Disney continues to welcome LGBT
individuals and families as the battle
with Ron DeSantis continues to rage
folks I don't think this is a battle Ron
DeSantis has even a chance in hell of
winning all of those stories and more
when we are joined by producer Pat on
today's bonus show please sign up at
joinpakman.com you go a long way to
supporting the work we do and it feels
good to sign up and say I'm a David
Pacman show remember it's a great thing
just got an interesting email actually
about two women bonding on a flight
about their David Pacman show
memberships very interesting story sign
up at joinpakman.com we'll see you on
the bonus show we are here all week